who's on the album oh [__] I got Conway
on there I got uh I got freeway on there
shout out my bro freeway man he came
through
um I got uh Jillian Haynesworth she's a
poet from the town okay I got my man
Terry King on there shout out my man
Terry King he's an awesome comedian and
I got Cody Sevilla she's an awesome
artist she she sings she raps she does
it all so when you hit freeway for the
future is it pretty like just do you got
to pay for it I'll tell you how how I
even got that feature so I uh Beanie
Siegel and freeway they both came
through Buffalo and they had a show and
I was at the studio that night and um
Conway was supposed to pull up and come
to the studio and they were gonna pull
up so they pulled up uh I'm sorry uh
beanie and free they pulled up and um we
was just sitting in the studio just
vibing and so uh I met DJ Coles he he
was like yo start playing your album
yeah and so you know beanie and uh free
they came in the stool and Kyle never he
never came through sounds about right
uh bro came you know what I'm saying
they came in the studio
and uh you know I'm playing all my all
my records from about some certainties
that I had so far and uh I got this
record on there it's called out here
that came on and the flow that I use on
there is just crazy
it's almost kind of like some freeways
right you know what I'm saying uh he's a
big inspiration to me for sure and so uh
you know the record comes on and I just
see him so he's sitting in the corner
I'm sitting in like the middle of like
the studio he's sitting in the corner
and I'm watching him like his whole
reaction is just like yo this showing
this crazy like you know what I'm saying
going back and forth and um you know the
song goes off and I'm like yo bro like
it's room for you on there he's like
well I'm like yo there's room for you on
that record like I see you over there
vibing like you know hop on it man you
know what I'm saying like he was like yo
run it back so we played it back he was
like yo let's do it so immediately like
I'm like yo my man Tony boy will say I'm
like yo Tony boy load up the session
let's get it he did his verse right
there on the spot it was love I feel
like I was talking to Conway on camera
about his relationship with Beanie
Siegel and he insinuated that there
might be something coming down the
pipeline with Beanie Siegel I wish I
knew but that lock load is a crazy
record yeah that was like that was like
a year and a half ago yeah yeah lock
load is crazy oh my God